I think intelligence and Consciousness
are completely different Notions one can
be objectively measured that is
intelligence as it is defined in in Ai
and computer engineering computer
science intelligence just means a
certain way of processing data that
leads to effective solutions to problems
or answers to questions without the user
having to give a recipe for how to
produce the answer how to produce the
solution so it's basically an objective
way of processing data that leads to
Solutions
Consciousness is what it is likeness it
is the felt qualities of experience
these are completely different things so
even if we achieve General Ai and I
think we will I mean I work in an AI
myself I think we will achieve General
AI that doesn't entail or imply or even
suggest that that goes hand in hand with
private conscious in their life at all
why did why would it it's a completely
arbitrary Association that we make now
people might say well Bernardo but if an
AI claims to be conscious and behaves
just just like a human and passes the
Turing test wouldn't we have to take it
seriously I would say not at all because
it was constructed to look and behave
like a human I mean we can construct the
dog tomorrow that looks like a human
will that similarity be grounds for us
to suspect that the doll might be human
of course not it was construct directed
to look like like it in exactly the same
way that the chat bot looks like a human
talking doesn't provide any grounds
whatsoever for us to think that it may
have conscious private conscious in
their life like a human because it was
made to imitate a human it was
deliberately constructed for that
purpose so that provides grounds for no
philosophical speculation at all so I
think that the so-called ethical
problems of dealing with AIS that claim
to be conscious is equivalent to the
ethical problem of judging
um
the ethical imperatives of the Flying
Spaghetti Monster it's the same thing in
other words it's a non-existing problem
that we make up
to maybe give expression to our
repressed religious impulse or to
entertain ourselves but it's just not a
thing at all it's just not there AIS are
tools and we have to have safety
measures when we are using powerful
tools that's no different for AI a
nuclear power plant is a is a tool to
produce energy it can also kill us it
can be dangerous so we have to put
safety mechanisms in place to protect us
against the tool we created AI is the
same thing it's a very powerful tool it
can go berserk so we have to put safety
measurements in place not to get hurt by
the the tool AIS that we use that
doesn't mean that we have an ethical
problem in our hands at all not any more
than we would have an ethical problem of
about shutting down a nuclear reactor
and killing the thing we don't talk
about that problem in these terms it's
not like we have we cannot kill the
nuclear reactor it's alive if we shut it
down it will die no it's just it's a
tool and we take precautions against the
tool same thing for AI everything else
is just fantasy